welcome to screen junkies you know what
I love meth blue meth guys I'm pretty
pumped for Breaking Bad it returns on
August 11th for its final eight episodes
as a public service here's a little
refresher so you can just pop it on and
feel kind of caught up in case you were
wondering this is full of past season
spoilers what do you expect let's start
with Walter White he's a mild-mannered
chemistry teacher later becomes the one
who knows I am the one who knocks this
man has given a death sentence my life's
biggest ex whole cancer lung cancer and
operable he wants to make sure that his
family is financially taken care of that
family consists of Skyler Walt Jr word
Memphis and later baby Holly oh and then
there's also his in-laws DEA agent Hank
and klepto Marie Walt takes his
chemistry skills and decides to become
the Paula Deen of meth - all the n-words
he hooks up with old student Jesse
Pinkman yes science his favorite word is
[ __ ] they get a Winnebago steal some
school supplies and I'm not talking
about erasers round-bottom boiling flask
5,000 milliliters and he starts cooking
the most delicious blue crystal meth in
the universe may be blue but it's a bomb
once that meth hits the streets starts
to get real son I got to figure out how
to sell it
they got to kill some fools and they do
business with a maniac named Tuco tight
tight tight yeah this guy's a local Wow
out of this Heisenberg is born it's noon
Heisenberg he has a special hat season
two there's like a purple teddy bear
floating in a pool wall Jess get their
own crew combo skinny Pete Badger and
then they run into trouble
better call Saul crooked lawyer Saul
Goodman great Jewish name but not Jewish
exactly like Whoopi Goldberg that purple
doll is still floating in the pool Saul
hooks them up with Gus fring the Colonel
Sanders of meth can I help you sir
dudas scarily calm a man provides first
wait too damn late back what is up with
this doll you keep showing it
Jessie starts getting it on with the B
from apartment 23
she's his junkie landlady turned
girlfriend but in his most evil moment
of the series Walt gets super jelly and
lets Jesse's girlfriend die I got really
jealous a friend once so I went and
erased all his episodes Pawn Stars off
his TiVo the thing that Walt did that's
way worse
okay the purple doll is still floating
there what's going on so for a lot of
dumb reasons the girlfriend dying leads
to a plane crash and a heavy-handed
we're all connected six degrees of the
butterfly effect kind of thing the doll
we've been seeing falls from the plane
and into Walt's pool that worth it was
it Vince Gilligan season three starts
with Walt getting chased by some really
sharp dressed Mexican murder twins Walt
gets a new lab this place is better than
kitchen Stadium he also gets a new
assistant Gail I am a nerd or as I like
to call the newspaper editor from season
5 of The Wire remember that wire heads
Gail is too much of a dork for wall-e
Lois drifty folding so he brings back
Pinkman hello the [ __ ] is back who saw
boner then Walt saves Jesse's butt with
his Pontiac Aztek run ugliest car in TV
history but it gets great gas mileage
it's easy to clean thug guts off the
hood Walt's brother-in-law DEA agent
Hank start sniffing around Gus Gus sends
the murder twins after him but Hank has
got nine lives and he smokes their asses
Gus has had enough of their shenanigans
explain yourself he's gonna kill Walt
and let Gayle take over using Walt's
secret recipe
I was wondering how soon might be able
to take over the lab that is until Jesse
pops Gail
now Jesse's the one who knocks [ __ ]
season 4 is getting bananas this is
crazy
but my favorite character on the show
might be Mike Ehrmantraut you are not
the guy you're not capable of being the
guy I had a guy but now I don't you are
not the guy no-nonsense badass grandpa
Gus hires him to be Walt's gun-toting
babysitter all out of options killed me
you have nothing
Gus decides to put the dynamic duo of
meth back to work after relieving some
stress with a box cutter get back to
work meanwhile Jesse's all bummed out
over his first murder the first one's
always the hardest so he turns his house
into a non-stop party which is also
kinda like a crack house too while he's
laid up Hank gets really into two things
solving gales murder - WWWE figure that
is cool and rocks it's a mineral
collection sorry
minerals meanwhile Gus tries to drive a
wedge between Jesse and Walt
can you cook Walters finger what - when
Jesse back over Walt goes and poisons a
child who do you know who's allowed
children to be murdered Gus then in a
plan straight out of Looney Tunes Jesse
and Walt trap Gus with the old
wheelchair full of dynamite trick it
takes his face off Walt wins by one
what's better in the cage face off joke
or a Harvey Dent two-face joke season 5
part 1 we start with a flash-forward
that sets up the inevitable Scarface
ending Walt buys a huge gun
co-production note the writers of the
show wrote that scene not knowing where
it was gonna go hopefully they have some
idea by now in order to get rid of some
incriminating evidence Jesse comes up
with a brilliant plan and an even better
new catchphrase yeah match magnet fool
us magnets more in the insane clown
posse
then he meets the Germans and one of
them commit suicide with on
defibrillator Claire
leaving a character named Lydia as
Walton Jesse's new business partner she
combines Skyler's complaining with
Murray's hysterical rambling no you're
making a mistake this this was not me I
swear to God I didn't do it I'm kind of
looking forward to seeing Lydia kick Joe
meanwhile Skyler and Walt have hit a
little marital speed bump what are you
waiting for for the cancer to come back
but on the upside Walt has found a
creepier Dumber Jessie to work with
Landry from Friday Night Lights aka Todd
won like Jesse isn't such a prude about
child murder no Jesse gets bought out
Mike gets bought out but he's got too
many loose ends
cue the epic shank montage shank Nadeau
and then Walt kills Mike
the carwash guy with the eyebrows gets
to live but Mike gets killed come on
Gilligan
finally Walt has agreed to get out of
the biz Wow looks like he and Skyler
gonna ride off into the sunset with a
giant pyramid of money until Hank has
the ultimate ocean moment just a cop
taking a number two and whammo Wolf's
brother-in-law opens on some Walt
Whitman and sees w w and he's tracked
down Eisenberg Walter what you got me do
to some very convenient bathroom reading
here we are so how's the series gonna
end is Jessie gonna die does Murray
shoplift again will we end up with
another pizza on the roof leave your
answer in the comments section below
best answer gets a $25 Best Buy gift
card courtesy of cinnamon out from that
spot I want to thank you for watching
screen junkies I'm Hal Rudnick bye-bye